is the white house or dhs
instructing border agents to refuse
ride-along requests
from reporters it's coordinated through
the department of homeland security and
i'd point you to them for any additional
questions about the logistics of press
access
if you all wanted to grant access to the
press
couldn't you just tell dhs to do it
again we fully support transparency and
i would encourage you to talk to the
department of homeland security about
any requests you have for press access
or
what you're looking to come accomplish
at the border
well we're smart enough to know that
that's not really an answer to the
question that was asked
still no indication from white house
press secretary jinsaki on when the
media might get to see the conditions
inside those overcrowded border
facilities
and this the biden administration is
said to be
limiting contact between border
officials and the media
officials say they were told to deny
press requests
for ride-alongs with agents and to
forward
any inquiries to the d.c press office
for approval
joe koncha is a media and politics
columnist for the hill and a fox news
contributor
first of all just your reaction to that
and can we work around that to get to
the facts
one would think i always heard the
saying harris that the buck stops here
right the buck stops with the president
with the white house for the white house
press secretary to say oh you know go
talk to dhs
we really can't handle that i thought
this was supposed to be purge and saki's
own words
one of the most honest and transparent
administrations that we'll see and
instead we see
a media blackout at the border imagine
if president trump had done this
the words authoritarian and dictator the
quota would run out clearly and we know
why there's a blackout
now don't we you have facilities that
are at 100 percent being overrun the cdc
says these facilities should only be
filled to 50 because of covid and now
they're at 100
you have migrants by the hundreds
testing positive for covet and then
being released
into the u.s population that is
literally a super spreader event
when saki was asked about this she said
she didn't have any updates she has to
circle back but it's certainly something
you support
okay so if it's certainly something that
they support just simply say
allow the media in let's see what's
going on here but instead it's the usual
dodge harris
but there's a layering onto this and as
journalists
this is really a problem when you start
to tell the very people
who are doing the work of this that they
are not are not allowed to talk to the
press what is going on behind the scenes
is there an
inherent threat there to their jobs like
what does that look like because we can
foia we can freedom of information
act information and if they want to talk
and
put it in writing we can foia for that
what is this administration trying to
say is is this more
a hit on us as reporters
it certainly seems that way and it's
it's typical of the pattern
as far as not allowing any access to the
president for instance in terms of a
press conference not being held for nine
weeks into
an administration and at the border the
fact that casey stegall had a great
report before
it's not only that he's putting in
requests saying okay we want to see
these facilities and other news
organizations are as well
the requests aren't even being returned
in this situation so
uh look this is one of the biggest
problems right now
for the biden administration it is
overshadowing everything and to your
point before when this news conference
comes up in nine days
guess what's going to dictate that news
conference if they just held it right
after the covet bill was signed maybe
that is the story of the day
this will be the story of the day nine
days from now 90 days from now and for
the foreseeable future it's only going
to get worse as the warmer as the
weather gets warmer hairs
well and i do want to throw in that at
least one of those facilities you
mentioned that they're at 100
capacity one is at 729 capacity
my goodness i mean they're just over i
know it's unbelievable